One of the issues with Destiny's narrative about the Queenman
and Justa communities is that he uses
he uses this narrative about them being doxers to justify Destiny's
campaign of doxing against them. So, yeah, but I personally have
seen that happen in like on Justa community end and
What?
What? What the [__] is he talking about? Okay, hold
on. Apparently, we should have we should have the evidence here.
I sure hope Listen, this is the one point where I'm like, "Okay,
I've I've definitely pushed back on Lunar Box slander on this
stream, okay? If I think people are being like unhinged about
Lunar Box, I'll go, "No, you're wrong."
For the love of God, please, for just this one time you got to
you got to be like, "Hey, that's crazy It's a crazy thing to
assert. You got to actually provide evidence to that." About
the So, I I've heard hear this a lot and I'm I don't know what
to do with it because similar to what Tony said, you know, someone
can say something and then they can redact it or delete it. And
it's just like, I've heard the same thing for the Queenman like
crowd. Like they'll dox people, they'll say and then they'll
delete it or redact it. People um
their narrative's going around around about the Queenman community
and it's sort of there's like Queenman does Queenman does not
allow doxing. Queenman does not support it at all. Like people
have been um banned from his community for it. There was a guy
who posted like That's and that's true for Queenman's community,
the spicy
um pretty much all of these communities. The only place that
has doxing is Kiwi Farms and Queenman doesn't control what the
people do on Kiwi Farms.
The Kiwi Farmers who are known doxers are not allowed
in Queenman's community.
He bans them. He banned a guy who posted um one BE tweet in spicy
chat cuz he was showing somebody else something that had happened
and it was like a lapse of judgment. The guy is I know the guy
is like apologized.
He feels very bad, but that was an example of something that
they um that Destiny repeated as being like this community are
rampant doxers.
Um So, but it's just >> Yeah, so this is my problem though.
This is why it's a tech question because if I want to be in one
of these communities like Queenman's and simultaneously have
like an account on Kiwi Farms or something that I want to dox
people on. To me, this would be trivially easy to do and not
get caught.
could have like a separate account and a separate thing, but
then Yeah, what am I supposed to [__] do about that?
What what am I supposed to do?
What's the prescription?
Like what are
Like people don't talk about doxing in these communities. People
don't do it. I don't do it. I don't allow it. >> Yeah, well,
actually you guys you can't Sorry, you can't stay in the Discord
unless you submit to internet history
All Discord users will be required to have an instance of TeamViewer
running so that I can monitor your activity at all times.
A terrible
If somebody's like on Kiwi Farms on one name and there's no way
to link them
like a Discord user, how are you supposed to ban them? Well,
exactly. This is my problem, too. Is like again, if I wanted
to do this, this would be extraordinarily easy to do and get
away with and like all I have to do is just not say that I'm
doxing this person or like this person should be
Like all you have to do is be a little careful with your language
and it's it's not difficult. Yeah, but Queenman is careful with
his community. >> what do I do about that? Well, not Queenman.
I'm talking about like the his his community. His server's kind
of like His community echoes that narrative.
Well, what does a spy do mean by that? Okay, but they don't they
don't people don't about doxing. The spy the guy has a legitimate
mental disability, by the way. Well, but dude, you don't have
to say I approve of doxing to like be guilty of This is what
I'm saying.
What are you What are you telling me that they're like There's
a there's a wink wink nudge nudge like There isn't wink wink
nudge nudge. There is no wink wink nudge nudge. I mean, so He
has a TBI? Is that Is that a joke or do you actually know that
from somewhere? Is that actually true? Did I just hit it like
perfectly?
Cuz it make total total sense.
I've I've heard that there is. I've heard people say similar
to what you said, Tony. Like I saw DMs. I saw messages and then
they get deleted.
So, the the
Like that I know the stuff you're talking talking about like
a Destiny segment that he did. He was talking specifically
about the thing that I mentioned
which was the only instance that he could point to of somebody
being doxed or was one of the only.
And that was deleted. The guy was banned. He was banned in spicy.
He was banned in Queenman's Discord and YouTube, I think.
Well, I'm not talking about just the one instance though. But
that That was one of the instances that he used as an example.
Sure. Well, let's assume I'm not I'm not talking about one of
these examples. Okay, well, give me an example. So, when did
that happen? Well, um Yes, cuz it's like a Destiny narrative.
I I know the clip where it comes from. I've saw him talk about
it. Um the issue is that it just isn't true. Like there is no
wink wink >> This is my Sure, but this is the problem like
it's potentially a narrative or it's potentially happening. The
same thing that you were saying like what Dan said like potentially
happened, but he he redacted it. So, like there's no proof. You
potentially raped a child. I think Lawson Harrison potentially
raped a child. I mean, there's no proof, but you know, it could
be like a wink and a nudge, you know? Just imagine imagine I'm
talking about that outside of the scope of this current conversation,
you know? He could potentially rape a child, you know, just cuz
we don't have evidence for it.
Like sure, but >> Like everyone's just kind of taking someone
else's word for what's going on.
Well, I You're welcome to go into Queenman's Discord and look
for people doing doxing. Like people don't do it. I don't think
that's the I don't think that's the So, again, I don't really
pay enough attention to this to have a strong opinion, but I
think
what people maybe know isn't I guess what I've noticed as well
cuz I I still watch Queenman sometimes.
Is that like
You you obviously you can't dox in his server and like endorse
it anywhere, but then there is sometimes like this issue
more than once you will see in like Queenman's chat like a very
Well, I mean, I don't like that framing. You can't endorse it
anywhere. I mean, like if someone
Like someone could theoretically make an argument that they believe
doxing is okay in a certain instance. I wouldn't ban them for
arguing they think doxing is okay in a certain instance. But
if they were calling for someone to be doxed or encouraging the
doxing of someone, then that's a bit different.
I don't like that. I don't like that framing just sets me off.
The idea you can't you can't endorse it. No, someone could theoretically
I can imagine someone making an argument about believing doxing
was justified and I wouldn't ban them for that.
frequent like referencing to like fake like notable Kiwi Farms
doxers, right? Like people who are actually doxed lots of people
on Kiwi Farms and are have a reputation for being the ones to
go and find their addresses and who are like >> Yeah, okay.
What are you supposed to do when Destiny makes Blahv like a [__]
main character in his streams?
How do you cover Destiny without talking about this [__]
Blahv guy? And obviously, people who [__] hate Destiny
are going to
think it's [__] hilarious when bad things happen
to him.
Like what what can you do about that?
Like with everything else. And like so the fact that you can
have like a wall of text from a chat spamming like affirmations
of this person. It seems Okay, Lunar Box has literally seen that
good example that Destiny brings up where it's literally like
it's about Destiny directly interacting with Blahv and the chat
spams like W
I'm like, "Okay, guys. Okay, settle
Like that's it.
It's like the most nothing ever.
Whatever. It's like Yeah, like there's a I I don't know how you
moderate like an overlap like that. I don't know what you do.
But that's like that's what you do. You're talking about um Do
you want me to not say the name? Is that You can say Blahv if
you want, yeah. Okay. Yeah, like they're saying like W Blahv.
An issue with Blahv is that like one is people do doxing which
is like I think is terrible, but also
I know that he's one of the big contributors to the Destiny thread.
He's written a bunch of like big things. I haven't read the Destiny
thread of I >> spamming W Blahv because because Blahv got
Destiny to directly engage with him. That That's why I could
they I'll put it like he got under his skin that Destiny's directly
responding. So, obviously it's directly respond to your Kiwi
Farms trolls.
It's just like, you know, it like the the point there is obvious
and it's nothing to do with
"Oh, we love doxing. Actually, we love doxing. Doxing's based,
actually." It's literally not that.
But the the thing with like talking about Blahv is that he is
if you're covering Destiny
you wind up talking about Blahv sometimes and sometimes Blahv
wins and because Queenman's community has a lot of people who
dislike Destiny
you know, sometimes Blahv gets one over on Destiny. Sometimes
they'll say "W
So, I don't know. Yeah, but is there not also Is there not also
the understanding in uh Again, I'm I don't know how you moderate
this. I'm just asking. Um Is it also the case in Kiwi Farms where
some of these doxers will are quite acknowledging of the fact
that like the Queenman chat like glazes
Um I haven't read any Um Well, yeah. Uh Blava said that.
But again, like what Learnabox is saying, like what what can
I do about
Well, unless I ban people from glasing Kiwi Farmers, but that's
such a weird
What a what what an what a bizarre rule to set in place, you
know? Like that that's the only prescription.
I don't I don't know how else you deal with that.
Enough of the threat to know. Okay. Also, I just want to again,
but how you moderate that, I don't know, cuz if they're not in
Queenman's community, they're just Yeah. interacting in this
indirect ways. Yeah. Also, I would just want to give a really
huge appreciation for Mick and chat with the one W bad empanada.
Like you're making a choice you're making a point in >> Okay.
Well, you're saying that you won't fault me for it. So, what
do I do about it? So, what do I do?
Yeah, drama content is adjacent to Kiwi Farms all the time cuz
that's where people go to archive discuss.
Yeah, that's like a big website for
So, there's a lot of crossover in
I just don't know what you're supposed
Like what what do I do what do I do with
Yeah, I feel like the prescription basically is stop talking
about Destiny. Why don't you just stop talking about that? Why
don't you just stop saying Destiny's a bad guy? Why don't you
just stop doing that?
Um no.
Like what the [__] is this? This is like it's such
a nothing.
I mean, to me it's nothing. I guess if this is your content,
this is your content, but
Why am I so fast? Oh, J Starks got me up. Okay.
That's totally insane. That's completely
I'm sorry. I didn't say I didn't see I didn't watch any of the
clips, but she was like messaging me about something going on
in the stream or something. And I was like, "Oh, would Learnabox
have pushed back against that? You would have said something,
right?" She's like, "Yeah, he did." She's like, "I said something
in chat, so he pushed back against it." I haven't heard any pushback
at all. Hopefully Hopefully Easy for you to say. Against
Push back against what?
What from me?
If I'm Yeah, I'm probably not pushing back cuz I'm barely listening
to this conversation. Like this was just I will probably do this
again. I don't know. There's like a little there's a whole thing
that gets
There's like a mixed incentive, you know, cuz I like having Dan
on stream and bringing all of his the people who hate him on
as well. Like for me, the upside is that that's kind of entertaining
to me. Like it's good content. It's easy. It's very easy. The
downside is is that every time I do this, it becomes a complete
feeding frenzy and somehow always ends up in the craziest like
most deranged death threat
um like lefties who hate me.
So, that's kind of annoying, but
I don't know. Maybe it's uh
It's not that bad. It's probably worth
But yes, I'm sure Dan said a few things that he we obviously
said things I disagree with because I was
screaming at him for the [__] brothel
Uh But I got I don't even I Why do I need to explain myself?
It is so stupid.
I Spider, you're here. Why Spider, why don't you press this guy
with your evidence, Spider? Hey Spider, you you were just watching
this. Are you still
Spider, why the [__] DIDN'T YOU SAY ANYTHING HERE?
YOU
Like this guy just makes [__] up with no evidence.
Says, "Oh, I saw it and then I it's been deleted and I swear
I saw it." You don't call him out. You don't say, "Hey, that's
totally You should have clipped the jerk Dan's like cut off and
and cut his balls when people were accusing him of deleting things,
right?" Why don't you do the same for me, bro? What happened?
You want a manly disabled guy to fight for you? Well, currently
I got nobody fighting for me. So, yes, I want a manly You want
a manly disabled guy
disabled guy who's in my server who participates all the time
to say, "Hey, what happened there?" Yes.
I told you he's on my side. Sure, sure. Okay, ask him, bro. I
just want to point out that you cut Dan's Alton's balls when
people did the same thing to him. And when it happened to me,
Spider, you stayed silent. You remained silent. Okay? I see you,
Spider. I see how you move. It will not be forgotten. All
I don't know. What this is a whole drama now. What?
Because there's like 50 [__] claims getting spammed
back and forth between Tony and Dan.
And I think I think I've probably Whatever they're talking about
here, I've just gone on a tangent to talk about this [__]
Azalea tweet.
I don't know, man. This is a it's a weird space. I don't
What was he saying? Well, maybe I could have pushed back more,
but I did press Dan when he started wrongly grouping us on and
with the brothel stuff. Yeah, the brothel's supposedly having
some traffic and tax evasion issues, but lumping us on into it
like that he was involved is just misleading. And you probably
should have called out Learnabox in DMs or something for not
stepping in when Lawson's are bringing up doxing allegations
against your community. It's cuz I don't know the [__]
details about these doxing allegations. I think I said there
wasn't any good evidence for it. I didn't even mention like the
Kiwi Farms thing, but that like how do you moderate that? Again,
why do I need to explain myself to these [__] people?
I don't give a [__] me. It's annoying. I don't know
why I'm getting like
I think this is probably Can we handle this kind of
for the occasional good panel content?
Uh people were spamming that like 1-minute clip where they're
just talking and they're like, "Oh, Learnabox isn't pushing back
or saying anything." It's like, "What? Really? I'm not speaking
over people yapping for a minute and a >> have to lie.
Yeah, here's the doxing I I I agree with you. You know what?
I agree with you. You don't have to play the
Well, no, you do have to play the game. You can have fun and
have principles at the same time, Dan. It's okay. >> You
have to play the game. You You what? You have to play the game.
I don't want to say um like if you don't play the game, you're
like so tied just Right? Do I personally care about Kaya? I could
give a [__] about Kaya just like I could give a [__]
about Learnabox's dog or anyone else's dog. I ain't met I don't
like watching animals get hurt, but I don't care about other
people's dogs. Not not in the slightest. I don't care. Like I
don't want it to happen, but it's not like I have a personal
relationship with a dog. So, and neither does anyone else who's
talking about this issue. They don't know Kaya. They don't know
the [__] dog, right? They care only on a broad spectrum
as much as I care is that I don't want animals to get hurt. Okay?
Like
That said, yeah, it's it's fair to push this because it hurts
Hasan and Hasan is a bad person and the goals are accomplished
as a result of that.
I can't believe Learnabox wouldn't push back against it. Oh,
man.
Good job. I don't know what to say.
Didn't Lav make false allegations about Hasan implying he slept
with a 17-year-old? Why is she still in your
Um even Erin is like within the good graces of these guys. I
just don't Whatever. They've got their own thing. It makes them
happy. Good. Good for them. I
You got to perform.
I don't know, man. I don't know.
It gets into a stage where like when it's arguing over the political
stuff or like the I guess occasionally there's drama that everyone
talks about like the caller, so it's like relevant. It's kind
of funny, but um beyond that like whatever the [__]
this is and people are getting hyped about, I don't give a and
you shouldn't either. Like what the [__] wrong with
you? What's wrong with you?
Just see if there's a comment here.
People were saying I'm like out in this clip or in this conversation
because I'm not like challenging or like screaming at Dan for
every innocuous thing he says, only like 75% of them or whatever.
It's like, "Dude,
[__] off. Like [__] off."
Uh nope. That's
I I don't think I had any criticism at all for Learnabox in that
part of the conversation, did I? The only person I out to at
the moment is probably like
cuz that guy speaks a lot of [__] on me, it turns
out. Um not like good faith criticism or whatever. Not like it's
it's like snark but, you know,
Oh, is he just going to have like one little clip? Oh, boy.
I just It's super easy to We need to have this conversation at
some point. Hold on.
Hold on. I'm sending DMs right now.
I just told Learnabox, you me and Queenman need to chat at some
point here so there isn't incomplete information getting passed
by chatters who have a vested interest.
>> I tend to have a pretty high threshold
taking [__] from people, I guess.
Uh whatever. >> It's late for him, no? I mean, he just
ended his stream 30 seconds ago, so
>> There if those opportunities present themselves again,
those brain dead drama streams, we'll do them because they're
funny and they're easy.
It's good uh piano and guitar practice.
Gets me on my on my instruments.
If I have to If I have to wake up if I have to set my alarm and
sleep 3 hours so I can go on Learnabox's stream and talk about
this, I'll happily do that. I'm just
I'm I'm literally sending Learnabox a DM. If he doesn't answer
me, I'll tell him, "Hey, I'm going to sleep, but I'll talk. Let's
just set up a time to talk cuz I think this needs to be talked
about at this point."
What did Queenman say about you? Why are you even asking me that?
Shut up. Like I don't even know why you would Okay.
A regular viewer. Well, what what do you what do you do?
Ryle very much needs me to look at this tweet about Queenman
right now. Where is the Where is the Queenman tweet?
This one? Substance tweet? You love to see it.
Uh I hope this is I think this is Yeah, it is. Okay. This is
Is Queenman also making comment on the the whole Lawson Harrison
situation on the Learnabox stream?
Not good times, okay? Not good. Looks just mad at me right now.
I didn't see the clip, but apparently he said I was being I was
being snark-brained about him because I made the joke in Jstark's
about his father being involved in war crimes, which isn't true,
obviously, but I joke
Hold on. Did Wait, did Lotterbox see a clip like that? I didn't
even see Lotterbox react to this. What?
Lotterbox watching something from our
Did I miss something? talked about it because a bunch of people
are on his stream lying about me again, and he won't say anything
about it.
Yeah, it's obviously tongue-in-cheek. It's obviously
I just I said, "Oh, there's no proof that his parents are
Just like say it's just By the way, I hope Lotterbox took some
guidance from me there. Oh, there's a claim made about you in
my chat that seems like it could be, you know, possibly false.
Oh, I'm going to go ahead and clear that up for you.
I'm going to go ahead and and say what the truth is just so you
don't feel like I'm, you know,
helping people on you or help people, you know, slander you or
something.
Not that Queenmu was doing that. It was obviously a joke, but
I'll I'm still going to make it clear. >> It's like we
just sit there and try and still man this [__]
knock with Dragon of Lawson Harrison, mentally disabled loser
along with his
>> No, sorry, not editor. It's There is Stardust to his
a scum just, you know, worthless piece
But spider is what I meant. Also true. >> [__]
just total
either lying or sitting there nodding nodding along.
I make a I make So, I made the joke about him in Jstark's chat
Sure. Yeah, I know I know he runs Lotterbox club channel. That's
what I meant. That's what I meant.
David $5.
Funny? A fun fact is Boris was bumping elbows and wearing a mask
with the Muslim women in 2024 he just doesn't like touching them.
Okay, nobody actually cares about Don't give Don't give Queenmu
$5 to comment on UK politics or he'll keep doing UK politics,
Kimberly. Do you understand? You're actually This guy over.
So, yeah, I made the joke in Jstark's chat and then I was like,
Queenmu could make so much money right now, I'm not even joking.
If Queenmu loaded up his stream, cuz I'm thinking about doing
this as well. Somebody suggested this to me. I'm just taking
Cherry's suggestion from me. But she's like, "You should do the
Sunday thing and switch between politics and drama, and then
you just start on politics, and if people want to go to drama,
they can donate." Queenmu should do that, right? Hey, I'm going
to do this extremely boring, nobody gives a [__]
UK politics right now, which is the content he's invested in,
so it's fine. But and then just make people pay if they want
him to go to drama. You want me to skip the drama, you feed the
drama meter, okay?
He makes so much money.
Jstark is no racist, that's true. And I'm like, "Wow, you Really,
we can't just go around making baseless claims about everyone?"
Or something like that. So, like the point was I was It's just
I'm just around cuz it's annoying that Yeah, it's That's the
That's the whole joke. We obviously get >> every two or
three months
there's like another clip of
you know, some worthless piece of [__] lying about
me over there or
So, you know,
We're basically Taiwan over here on this part of the internet,
okay? And And like this DGG community is like China, and everybody
knows, okay, all the other streamers are the rest of the place
in the world, they know a ton of viewers, a ton of manufacturing
happens there, they want their cheap goods, they want their money,
right? And so they're like, "Well, yeah, maybe Taiwan isn't a
country. Maybe these guys are like a doxing community or something.
I don't know." It's like this strength strategic
where they they try to they don't lean into it directly, but
they're like, "Well, I don't know, could be the case. I suppose
it could be the case.
You know, maybe maybe maybe."
Okay, stand up business. >> The moment they start talking
about how
it's all just lies propagated by Destiny, Lotterbox is like,
"I don't want to talk about Destiny. I don't want to talk about
Destiny. Stop this." But before then, when it's like, "Oh, we're
just going to sit here and lie about how
yeah, Queenmu's got a doxing server and all this [__]
It was a totally fine >> totally have that conversation.
That was totally chill. We should talk about that. That's an
awesome conversation, actually.
Feels a little frustrating. Understandably so. I can just say
I'll just sit here and yeah, this is like a totally reasonable
thing to think.
I feel like usually if someone comes on starts talking crazy
about Lotterbox, I'm like, "That's not true, come on." I feel
like usually I do that. I feel like usually I'm pretty good about
that, but hey.
I'm asking for the As am I, by the way. Obviously in this exact
situation >> for the bare minimum. I'm asking for a signal
that it's like rather than just like having this just like
come on and just like lie through his teeth for Massa.
Just totally with nothing said, just as if it's like a normal
person is just speaking about things they think and not like
not like a total subhuman.
Not like a total subhuman drone
who's come on to just re- repeat the lies of a borderline sex
offender.
Lotterbox does at least sometimes push back on Dan when Dan's
saying something that's like totally
his own. Like if he goes like totally I see Lotterbox push back
sometimes.
It's just, you know, annoying when it when there's someone that
I know
knows the truth
sits there just like black black face.
And the sad thing is is Lotterbox is very aware, like overall,
extremely aware that Destiny just maliciously
does creative writing about Pixie, like totally makes things
up and propagates them, and then his audience propagates it.
I know he's got a front-row seat for that. So, just when when
those same people, the same community, is doing that against
me or Queenmu, I just assume there'd be a little empathy. Just
a touch. Like a scosh. Just a little bit. But there there basically
isn't ever. while some
belching [__] is on there just lying through their
teeth.
Uh yeah, no, that's fair.
That's fair.
Seems like he's afraid of Destiny. Um
Uh it's tough to say. Like realistically
there's like uh you could be of multiple minds on it. There is
something there where probably
I don't know. There's there's other things that could be at play
there other than just being like a coward or something. I'm not
going to say he's like a coward for not clearing it up cuz he
could be trying something else. It's just I it's kind of brutal
when you're on the other side of it.
Uh yeah.
You are I Are you responding to me, Cherry? Are you responding
to
Oh, I see. Yeah.
Uh it's not really Listen, a lot of it, in my opinion, has to
do with he's trying to make sure that he can like keep doing
his content that he feels like is honest.
I I'm I have no commentary on it cuz I've not watched him in
a long time, so I don't know what his content is like. And is
he willing to like alienate a huge part of his audience who are
going to be a part of that cult? I don't know. I doesn't mean
I think he supports that cult. If it came down to push or shove,
like would he be on that side? I don't think so. I think he's
made it very clear that he thinks Destiny's like a
like total scum, right? I I think he's made that clear.
It's just that like every time you make that clear, you're going
to have fights with your community, it's going to continue to
like spiral around, and he'll have to keep talking about it,
So, there isn't benefit to it for him. Uh I think that it feels
like to me the benefit would be not letting this guy who just
lies about people continue to lie about people, but
kind of just not involving yourself is the better choice for
everybody's bank account. It sucks when you're the person being
lied about or when a lie about you that he's spun and that he's
propagated is being weaponized against you. Sucks to be the person
sitting there being like, "Well, I kind of get why you wouldn't
correct that cuz it it would cause you like some economic strife
or could lead to people, you know, disconnecting from your community.
So, I kind of get why you just wouldn't say
Like I can understand it, but it sure feels [__]
on my side of it, right?
Mm uh he He avoids it because he doesn't want to talk about it.
He avoids it for the exact reason I said.
He avoids it for the exact reason I Um it's not because of like
some special knowledge or he couldn't possibly speak on it. It's
not like that. Um he he might not want to speak on it because
he's got knowledge and he could be worried that he reveals it,
but it's not that he can't or something. There's nothing He's
not party to a case. He's not Yeah, exactly.
I don't even need him to speak on the Destiny thing. I just I
expect him to speak on the lies where it's like, "Yeah, you guys
are obviously just going to make some [__] up, right?"
Like you guys are obviously lying. You have to understand that's
an obvious lie, and if you can't present any evidence, I'm going
to have to tell you it's an obvious lie until you can present
any evidence at all.
Uh Kuroko, you're just not paying attention to the conversation
or you don't know what we're talking about. What happened was
he had Dan on, and then some DGGers joined and started talking
about mining Queenmu's communities doing doxing. He literally
came on and said, "Well, I the message is like deleted, but they
were actually in Jstark's server, and they were like, 'Somebody's
got to follow this guy,' and then there were a bunch of winky
face reacts to it." He literally totally fabricated a situation
and nobody said anything.
Literally nobody said anything.
Yeah, I understand. Then what's
You understand that that is a lie propagated by Destiny. You
can't just let people come on who are DGGers who are openly shilling
like total creative writing, totally malicious lies from
You can't just let them come on and say those things and then
go, "Well, I don't really want to talk about Destiny so we should
we shouldn't talk about this anymore." No, you you allowed the
topic to continue or to go on at that point,
You can't say
That's wild. It's just a wild
Oh, sorry. I mean, you can't and be like an honest person at
the same time. You can totally do that, but it's totally
The box is mad at me like
Big part of it is not wanting to [__] to stick your
neck out for communities that relentlessly [__] relentlessly
[__] on you, but that's a generalization content
creator to content creator. Well, it's but this community doesn't
and I've actually gotten super far out of my way, even upsetting
people to like say, "No, I don't think Lunar Box is doing this.
No, I don't think Lunar Box is doing
And I I sit out here I like actually cape for this guy and then
I watch somebody go on his stream and just talk about this. It
feels weird. But also, it sounds like it got discussed today
or something. So, maybe maybe it was cleared up today. I've no
idea.
Um do we have like a time stamp for this? Is there a time stamp
for him getting mad about Lunar Box or some chat that happened
on my stream?
Cuz we can find that. I'd go look for it, but I'd need a time
stamp.
Think it was very brief.
All right, I think so. I have no idea. I'd be totally down to
talk to Lunar Box at some point here if you wanted to talk about
it.
Because again
the thing to me is what I want in terms of a signal or what I
think would be appreciative or I I sorry, what I would appreciate
in terms of a signal is I don't As the guy who runs this channel,
as the guy who leads this community, I can identify that that's
completely made up, that's completely fake and I've never seen
any evidence of this at all and I know for a fact that the person
who made that up is somebody who lies about other people, too.
That's what that's what I want to hear from the person who runs
that community is, "Hey, that's totally made up. I know that's
made up because I watched the person who made that up. I watched
content or I've heard of content where they make where they say
those things and I know they make things up about other people.
I know they just totally lie about other people. So, I'm going
to say unless you can give me some evidence, that is an obvious
lie and you should probably feel bad for propagating obvious
lies."
Uh I don't think that's the case for many uh yeah, I don't think
that's the
We'll see. I just want it like all out there on the record kind
of thing. We'll see. I I don't know if he calls himself a centrist,
but he's basically kind of rejected liberal values in saying
that >> Sorry guys, there's some kind of mix-up with my
um
We need for you We'll check this out just shortly. >> hear
me now? Sending games right now.
We can hear you. We can see you.
Oh god.
He's about to blah blah blee blah his way through this conversation.
>> was used to describe such a broad array of things that
had not enough Did Did you abandon the Drew Pavlou thing?
I sorry, I I like started watching it and I'm like, "Okay, I
get it." Yeah.
We love brown people here or something.
I I like I understand what the arguments are going to be and
I understand Drew's going to take like the cringe I'm going to
try to be like pro ethno
centrism in some way without really claiming it. I don't know.
The ethnic British majority is being
Yeah, I don't. He got pushed into kind of claiming at one point,
but yeah,
Yeah, I just figured there'd be like three clips that could have
summed up the entire debate and I probably don't have to watch
the whole thing. Well, am I crazy cuz Lunar Box
Is Lunar Box
I mean, I wouldn't doubt he's got some If he's got significant
parentage from Lebanon, he's probably got some heritage, right?
Yeah, but he's not like I would he he doesn't Well, no, Drew
Pavlou thinks he's like called him like six times.
I mean, maybe the nose hits him. Maybe the nose is a whammy.
He called him he called him like six times and he's like shouting
at Lunar Box like, "You should be grateful. You should be grateful.
I'm defending Israel on social media." No joke. Yeah, this this
like happened.
Wait, why? Why?
It was pretty awesome. It was pretty >> Wait, why did that
Yeah, he was like saying Listen, I can go back and watch that.
I don't mind going back to watch that. >> Yeah, just find
just find the clips of him talking about Lunar Box being and
how Lunar Box should be grateful for the defense he's giving
of Israel.
Listen, I I know they're good times. I just couldn't watch the
whole thing. I was watching like the opening and I'm like, "Okay,
I don't Lunar politics, I don't give a fuck."
Second. Okay, this got to be it right there. Yeah.
He hopped on here and I was like, "Hey, we should talk about
this shit." >> that it starts about bonga politics, but
Drew obviously knows like nothing about British politics. He
just like it's
He sees on Twitter, right? He sees like J.D. Vance talk about
Britain and say, "Oh, there's Muslims there." And that that's
like the extent of his knowledge. I got the I got the idea that
basically from the beginning of the debate that I could probably
argue this point about as well as Drew could. Like I've never
cared about British politics. I actively like disdain watching
anything about it. And I feel like I probably have the same amount
of >> could argue that point better than Drew was, frankly.
Uh yeah, no, not shocking at all to me.
Hold on a second. Um can we can we get somebody with a time stamp
here if anyone's got a time stamp or a clip, either one?
Do you have Do you have a transcript?
There's not a transcript. I yeah, it's I was That's what I looked
for just now. I told it and there wasn't a transcript.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Maybe maybe Wiki TV got a transcript.
It's possible Wiki's got his transcript
I talked to Lunar Box. I was like, "Hey, we should have a conversation
before it's uh
I I get the feeling that I Somebody sent me the substance clip
of you talking about this. >> Oh, yeah. I I love Lunar
Box, guy. There's no I don't hate Lunar Box. I love Lunar Box.
We love Lunar Box here.
I just basically feel like probably there's some people with
like a certain vested interest just passing him specific stuff,
like really specific stuff and >> Yeah, I got the Well,
that's why I sent it. Somebody just screenshot my message saying
the joke about the sovereign [__] thing. And he he
was like, "Oh, I can't say it's not shit." I got the sense that
the Lunar Box is, you know, he's a little bit
I think he's also got some people around him who are just going
to share very specific things with them trying to look to either
start drama or
I don't know what.
He I feel like he's sensitive to like um if he feels like
I I think if he sees any sort of like bad and all of the type
jokes or lefty type jokes about him, I think that makes the hair
hairs on the back of his neck stand up, but hey, I could I could
be
I'm looking for where Where does What are the exact quotes I
should be looking for in this? >> Say say great greatful.
Greatful. Look for greatful.
Nothing for greatful. Nothing for greatful. Um
Uh social media.
Oh, this will be it.
This will be it. Somewhere around here.
Okay. Wait, do we finish the conversation around Lunar Box? I
was like looking at this transcript.
You were making comment. >> Um yeah, just play play the
play the Drew stuff. Play the Play the It's like that's about
Drew Pavlou. >> You're literally mentally ill. Dude, you're
mentally ill. I think Dude, you're you're Lunar Box Lunar Box
Lunar Box Lunar Box Lunar Box Lunar Box Lunar Box you are literally
extremely mentally ill cuz I've wanted to be I've actually been
one of the highest profile supporters of like Israel's right
to exist on social media over the past couple of years. And you're
saying, "Oh, well, you don't care about You're only doing it
cuz you hate Muslims." No, dude, that's actually extremely extremely
offensive and it's actually really evil of you to say that. How
about have some gratitude to me? They're they're like Look at
the world right now. Look at the world right now. Like half of
all these people There there are so many young people right now
who like literally want to Have you even Have you even thought
about thanking me? >> Drew's everywhere. This is just going
to be an emotional wreck. >> no, but have but have No,
but have some gratitude to me. >> this though. It's always
just like >> But it's true though. Literally But dude,
have some gratitude. Look at the fact that Look at how people
have treated the Jews over the past couple of years. I'm actually
an ally of the Jewish people and you're just like, "Oh, you only
care about because you hate Muslims." That's extremely offensive.
I've I've put my neck on the line. I put my neck on the line.
I got so many death threats from Muslims and stuff like that
over the past two years. You guys have no idea how many death
threats Drew Drew got for that Superman review, okay? That Superman
review
People coming for his neck. >> the He wants the Tommy Robinson
treatment. That's what Drew is looking
And then you say, "Oh, you don't care about You're only doing
it because you hate Muslims." That's extremely offensive. Like,
how dare you? Honestly, how dare you? >> I mean, you literally
just asserted that. You literally just tried to make it sound
like there was a There's like a higher murder problem of Muslims
in the UK as well. I don't suppose that your Center for Migration
Control that is definitely not >> why the Lounabox is Jewish?
Let's look for literally Jewish.
You had him with the PBD? That's crazy.
influencers living in the country. Yes, we have faced much worse
than that. Dude, you're literally Dude, you're literally Dude,
you're literally you're literally at this point. You're happy
WITH ISLAMIC EXTREMIST
HOLD ON. HOLD ON. Hold on. >> You're literally Dude, you're
literally you're literally at this point. You're happy WITH ISLAMIC
EXTREMIST
OH,
JESUS.
Uh He doesn't know. >> times, man. He says like he calls
him like six times. Crazy.
extremists living in Britain who want to kill you because you're
Jewish. I don't understand What do you mean happy with them living
here? If you want to have a discussion about paradox of tolerance,
that is actually an interesting
Why isn't Why isn't Lounabox correcting that? The problem is
I don't know why he didn't say anything.
have it because you don't even seem to You can't even >> if
you want to have a tolerant society, you can't have Islamic extremists
in it. So, you have to deport everyone who is >> He feels
like he's chosen. He's worked hard for this.
I mean, again, I'll just say as as somebody who's in the club,
you would know that nose puts you on a list like almost immediately
for most people,
I say I I feel like it's just it Jerry just says like Kelly had
defends Israel knows and it's like Yeah, no, unironically, Drew
is just racist. Yeah. Yeah, Drew is just racist. >> consider
to be an Islamic extremist? Yes, Islamic >> Hold on. Hold
on. Okay, I got a question. I got a question. How many Islamic
extremists exist now within
I would say basically every Hold on. Lounabox, do you think that
Muslim extremists living in Britain who defended the Manchester
synagogue terrorist attack, do you think that they should continue
to live in Britain or do you think they should be naturalized
and
That's I don't think you should deport someone right away for
their speech, no. Somebody who wants to kill you, who literally
wants to behead you because you're Jewish. Yeah, there are people
who have incited riots and tried to kill people in this country
who are locals as well. Yeah, I don't think deportation is really
the >> You can't deport locals. You don't deport locals
because exactly they're locals. They're part of the problem.
You're always going to have a criminal and that native element,
unfortunately. But, it's a choice to have foreign Islamic extremists
in your country, correct? It depends on because if you wanted
to have like a huge discussion about whether or or not there
you can be sending people away to different countries where they
might get like tortured or or if if they can even get sent to
any other different countries, yeah, that's a difficult question.
But again, you're not equipped to have the paradox of tolerance
opinion because you want to reduce immigration by 90%. Like,
that's not that's That's not That's not just accounting. That's
not just accounting for extremists. That's There's something
different going on there.
You know the current polling in Britain is like 80% want like
significant cuts to migration and want mass deportations, in
fact. Yes, and like something like half of people in Britain
think that there's more illegal immigration per year than legal.
And you know why that is the case? I'll explain to you why. They
think that people coming to the country, even on legal visas,
are illegals because they look at people in car washes and they
go, "Surely we could not be giving legal visas to people to just
do car washes." >> No, they think that because Nigel Farage
keeps dominating the news and is dominated by hamming up what's
going on. That's what's Yes, because Nigel Farage goes to the
coast with his little [__] Fisher-Price binoculars
and stares at people on boats all the time and people think that's
the biggest problem because it's dominating the story because
it's easier to see people coming in on boats. >> Dude, you're
literally It's happening in your country as well, in Australia.
There were more people coming in by plane than there were coming
in by boats even before sovereign borders, but everyone thought
the boats were the problem because you could see it, because
people could film it and scoops about it even though most of
them were coming by plane. I guess what, Lounabox, I've criticized
the liberal government for doing that in I don't think there's
anything I don't think there's more references to Lounabox being
Jewish in this one. I think we've watched them all. I'm lucky.
That's probably all.
Oh,
who is a very Jewish person? >> Oh, apparently Lounabox
himself as well. I might want to find that.
I didn't say that either.
I think.
Lounabox Let them rot in Indonesian detention centers where they
have no future, no asylum, no processing,
Subject to all kinds of criminal gangs, smugglers, human traffickers.
You are fine with that so long as they don't come to Australia.
I'm Muslim refugee
I'm Muslim refugee. Prick. Jesus Christ.
You're actually mentally ill. It's not my responsibility. I don't
know why you're like
thing to Yes, so yes, that's the thing. Yes, that's the thing.
Yes, that's the YES, THAT'S THE THING.
GOOD. JUST SAY THAT. YEAH, then don't pretend to care about them
going to a safe country.
Well, if they're I I want them to go to a safe country. Good
luck No, you don't because the only safe The closest safe country
for those ones The closest safe country for from Rohingya is
Australia.
That's the closest safe country. No, that's actually not true.
China is party to the refugee convention. They can go Hold on.
A Uyghur that feels persecuted in China and is trying to feel
flee the Uyghur genocide, where should they go? You You said
You said that Australia is the closest country. You can >> Drew.
Drew.
Hold on. Drew. How do He said it's not his closest safe country.
You're not like Are you safe as a Muslim in China if you
I mean, that's the case.
Uh everybody should have take their share, okay? Hold I'm having
said that, there's a couple things I want you to be thinking
about. Number one, you
Thank you, PBD. I just I I could hear the spirit, okay? The spirit
of PBD running through him there.
That's just my favorite clip in the world. I need to recut that.
I don't have the full clip anywhere. [__]
with it. And sorry, I don't have the the clip down thing. That
was the full >> to my question. >> to just start
blaming all of Lounabox's opinions because he's Jewish. I'm
I'm just not claiming that about him.
But, what is the goal here?
Is there Is there a specific goal?
No goals, just like it's funny. It's funny.
I'm going to link to tweet.
Sean Fitzgerald, AJW, I was today years old when I learned that
Amy Dangerfield had to learn Spanish in Miami because her Uber
drivers didn't understand the English word for no. We can all
relate to the struggle here.
What? You should want to assimilate. It's so interesting when
I moved from Maui, Hawaii, I lived there for 4 years and then
I moved to Miami. When I first got to Miami, guys, I had to learn
Spanish because of the Uber and Lyft drivers that refused to
assimilate. So, even basic words like stop, go, wrong way, no,
yes, they didn't understand. You should want to assimilate. It's
so Wait, what?
Correct me if I'm wrong.
That's not even a joke on her Australian accent. I believe the
Spanish word for
is in fact no.
Is that not Yeah, okay, okay. I Like, I wouldn't have known that
for sure, but
I didn't know that off the top of my head. No, I didn't know
that. But, I'm just saying that's
very interesting.
But, yeah, but these are like brown Uber drivers that refuse
to assimilate, okay? She's making an implication here. There's
a There's a reason she has to highlight that they don't understand
no, all right?
Why the Okay, I'm the only person who hears it. All right, fair
enough.
You got to hear. I'm probably
This is funny. I I'm sure this gets heated and funny and the
clips will be good from it. I I can't listen to like long-term
or long-form Drew Pavlou conversations.
Like, as much as they should be funny, it's actually just mostly
depressing to
Uh yeah, guys, there's He's just super engaging with it cuz
you know, he doesn't believe any of it. He's a racist.
Well, he kind of believes it. He can think about it like a little
bit. He thinks about that $1,000 that gets stolen from him and
then he's like, "Yeah, I really do actually hate all these brown
people." And he can like kind of work his way through it.
Hasn't intellectualized the position,
Drew is a bit of an energy vampire, yes, that he like he In fact,
he is kind of the prototypical energy vampire that he can just
like humiliate himself over and over and over again
and never ever feel bad. >> is full on story is is literally
I left my wallet and bag in plain view in my car unlocked
for a prolonged period of time and my stuff was stolen. So, now
we need to deport all the immigrants and no, I don't know who
stole it.
Like, what Okay.
I can't think of another place that would happen, okay? Certainly
not
if you were to go east, gentlemen, okay? >> Yeah, Japan.
Japan would never have that
Yeah. I Did you Did you hear that part of the way?
No. Oh, no, I literally just I literally just made up the exact
thing Japan is Yeah, he's saying that Japan's like a perfect
society basically.
Oh, man.
Oh, boy. Imagine a society.
Speaking of uh by the way
That's a liberal democracy that then What is one What is one
country one developed successful country in the world that's
a liberal democracy that doesn't take in like reason like fairly
high numbers of immigration? Literally just Japan. Literally
Japan. You want to be like Japan?
Japan is much better than Britain right now and it had it has
higher GDP
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
Starting to look like a lot of their population is above like
the age of 45.
Starting to look like that might be kind of a problem, guys.
You think that might >> I think that's sustainable. I think
that's really sustainable. This is probably a good thing, right?
There's a reason Shinzo Abe What's the culture like over there
again? What the what
I think it's really permit It's sort of like the French, right?
They take a lot of vacations. They take a lot of time off. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's like uh It's similar like the Spanish like they
take breaks in the early afternoon for a
Yeah, I think something like
per capita, lower inequality, less crime, less terrorism. In
so many different ways Japan is literally superior to Britain
right now.
Japan is not superior to Britain right now. Japan's had economic
issues for the last like three decades, okay? Their debt is expiring.
Japan's economy is literally better than Britain. Do you understand
that Japan is currently increasing migration because they cannot
sustain their state? At a very at a very low rate. At a very
low rate. At a very low rate. Can you explain why >> Yeah, it's
at a low rate because people lose their [__] whenever
migrants come to Japan. People freak the [__] like
and it's also the fact that Japan should remain culturally cohesive.
I want Japan to remain a Japanese society.
For the sake of them becoming an aging population and not being
able to sustain anything that they currently got and having a
tanking economy. It's better It's It's better than Japan basically
becoming culturally unrecognizable.
Nations can recover from war. Nations can recover even from two
atomic bombs on their cities. Listen.
Economic devastation, economically withering away and having
your whole society die off because you can't sustain any medical
services or any of your social services. Okay? That is If it
prevents
even one
assault situation, okay? It's It's already worth it. Yep. For
real. >> No race mixing. No interbreeding. Nope. Nope.
Nope. Even one Even one prevented, then it's worth it. Your whole
society >> can I can live with it when white people are
white people, but when it's brown people white people, I just
I can't That's too much. That's way too much. >> We got
to We got to shut it down. But they can't recover from being
completely
terraformed in the demographics just changing forever.
So, for the sake of demographics
really, you would have a shrinking economy. You would have a
tanking welfare state.
>> Dude, dude, the the British welfare state's tanking
right now as we speak. The economy in Britain's so bad. You've
had the Boris wave and it's not leading to any economic growth
at all. The The The Boris wave was because of horrible mismanagement
of immigration. Quite a lot of which has been reversed. >> Okay,
like like let's start through Let's Okay, let's go through some
of the British economic statistics, right? I
borrowing a hundred billion dollars this year, 13% 13% up this
year, public sector You're talking about borrowing when you just
brought up Japan. Are you mental? No, no, I'm going into this.
I'm going into this. Public sector net debt
>> It's like debt-to-GDP ratio. It's Japan's pretty great.
Has been forever. Although I guess Japan is like still At least
Japan is like I don't know investing in military. Like they're
going into debt, but
I don't know. They They've got like a pretty impressive navy
and [__]
It's like the the debt might actually be
It might not be that big a problem.
Uh it's not about dying off, Orjan. You understand that, right?
It's about people at your retirement age Or sorry, it's it's
about having a society that you can pay with the young people
through their taxes for social services for the retired
while the society continues to function.
Once you have like a massive amount of your society retired,
which in Japan is going to be a There's a massive population
like cliff coming, right? You're going to have like what 40 Sorry,
you're going to have like 60% of your society retired in Japan.
It's It's like over at that point. Japanese just never retire.
Well, that's basically what they're going to have to do, right?
People And I think that is happening in a lot of places. People
are just staying on at jobs like way, way, way later. Some people
hypothesize that's like as you increase living standards, people
can work later and longer and
and like maybe it won't be that bad. Like we raise the entire
the retirement age to 75 or something. I don't know if people
are going to like that though. Certainly the French didn't like
it.
What did they get their retirement age Their retirement age got
raised from like 55 to 58 or something, right? Didn't they riot
over that?
They try everything though.
When did they What was the retirement age change? 62 to 64.
They literally They literally rioted over this.
Not even 65, dude. Hey, wait, wait, wait. What's What's What's
What country among the five countries has the highest
Sure, then fix the underlying financial Ponzi scheme. That would
help. Sure, Orjan, you could say fix the underlying financial
Ponzi scheme, but ultimately social security and most of the
social safety net is a Ponzi scheme that works as long as you
have a slightly increasing population over
The way to fix that is you run as a politician. It's really easy
to fix that actually. You run and you raise the age on entitlements
significantly.
Guess what? Guess what happens when you run that policy? You
get zero votes.
The only thing There's three possible ways to basically fix most
countries' balance sheets, right? You can increase
Increase the tax base or cut spending. You can cut spending by
raising retirement age. You can cut spending by
I guess just gutting social services in general or you can increase
your tax base either by taxing people more, which also you can't
get elected on, or by bringing in immigrants. It turns out the
reason every country just brings in immigrants is because none
of them can run and win on lowering taxes or increasing the age
on entitlements.
You just automatically lose every election in every Western country
if you run on those two positions.
So, immigrants it is.
Pick one of those three.
And people pick brown people every single time.
Dumb Dumb very dumb dumb Canadian. Hello world. Give me any answer.
Prove that you're not dumb.
It's not like the resources are missing. It's the underlying
systems created that control it. You just said something schizophrenic
that means literally nothing.
Marginal tax rates. Okay, run on Run on tax increases. Gen X
detected. Mentally disabled Gen X detected. It's It's about the
systems, man. The systems are just like set up to go over. Okay,
go right then. Stop paying taxes.
Marginal tax rates. Listen, we can just tax our way through this,
guys. If we just tax the rich, they won't They won't totally
flee. They won't hide their assets. Won't matter. Won't matter.
Guys, it'll be so good. It'll be so good. You don't understand.
What happened in France when they did when they did this, Hello
world? You tell me?
Uh this Hello world guy is not going to engage with the only
example we have of a like significant marginal tax rate increase
and a luxury tax. He's not going to engage. He's not going to
engage. He's not going to engage. No, not protests. The wealthy
people fled the country.
Cuz guess what? When you're wealthy, you can just do that.
They're just going to hide assets. It's just going to lead to
deteriorating economic growth. You can You can bump it up a little
bit, but it's just going to It's You You do it hardcore, you're
just going to [__]
And I agree with that the rich should be taxed more. You can't
tax your way through this problem in basically any
Uh the system is the underlying way that debt-based financial
kick-the-can-down-the-road
institutions
Yes. Okay, you could You could say this. But like the the social
safety nets
are things that people expect.
And so you have to cut them in some way, right? You could say,
"Oh, change how they function." That means increasing retirement
ages. That means decreasing benefits. That's how you change how
they function. You make them cost less money.
That's how you change how they function. It's the only way.
Only way.
All right, guys.
You like the content, you go ahead and sub. I think I'm going
to keep watching this Pisco debate for a little bit here and
then we can see what's going on. I'll watch at least one or two
more sections. >> this painful?
It's painful, but it's pretty good content. I'm enjoying cuz
I'm just like calling out Japan [__] sucks. This
guy's a loser.
Uh he's okay. This is not a good conversation for him. He I'm
literally defining the problems that Pisco then immediately tells
him are the problems like every single time. It's very funny.
Who's Pisco debating? He's debating PF Young a couple weeks ago.
Yeah. If this guy got up like put in C cup for the
League of Legends videos,
I probably wouldn't speak out.
Uh yeah, you would.
Why are you lying?
I'm not.
You are.
Oh, I genuinely I think those are like, you know, you should
be tried for that.
You're saying an edgy thing you don't believe right now. You
know that, right?
I think he should be This guy should be tried and so should the
uh rap battle guy. He's going to He's going to have to get He's
going to have to get more extreme. Uh-oh.
Who's the rap What's the rap battle guy? Rowan Rowan. Destiny's
grilling Hutch right now and saying that Hutch was right about
you. You watching that Hutch stream earlier today?
That Hutch stream was really funny. Is it? What happened?
>> He basically like sees Oh, Kyle Kulinski like calls
him out for something. And he's like, "Well, no, I didn't do
this to Kyle. I didn't do I didn't like mislead with Kyle Kulinski.
I didn't mislead my thumbnails or titles about Kyle Kulinski."
Then he realizes he did, his editor did. And then he blames his
editor. And then eventually a little bit later he goes, "Well,
I guess it's my
He He like sort of starts just totally waffling all over the
place. He says that So, he basically said Kyle
equates Republicans and Democrats,
And then he realized that that's not true. Kyle was mad cuz he's
like, "That's the exact opposite of my position." So, it's really
[__] up for Hutch to say that. And then Hutch goes,
"Yeah, well, there's kind of like a bit of a clip chip not clip
chipping click baiting game that goes on on YouTube. Just like
when Kyle, you know, Kyle kind of lied about my content on his
stream. He said we had a heated debate, but I don't think it
got heated a single
It's like, "Brother, what?"
It was really goofy. >> Oh my god.
Yeah. I really hope Kyle watches that and responds. Be very funny.
Yeah, that'd be awesome.
What did you just like say to us?
Yeah, it was good times.
I think there's also Oh, Kyle also said that Hutch is like Destiny
and that he punches left all the time. While Hutch was trying
to like call Destiny out for something. So, Hutch was like in
the middle of calling Destiny out for being too black-pilled
or something. And then he like turns on this Kyle Kulinski clip
after getting a donation and immediately Kyle Kulinski says that
Hutch and Destiny are the
See you later, Kiriako. See you.
See here.
Shut shut
Oh, yeah. I Dude, okay. Guys, I don't care about this gay
I don't care about this gay song. >> please please. >> this
gay song, but I don't care. I'm literally never going to give
a [__] about this song. >> that link that?
You belong in a group home.
Oh, boy. Um Okay, what else we
What else we got? Somebody People are like so
I was asked not to cover Colorgate anymore and then people just
kept linking me stuff. Apparently, Ludwig totally dissed about
Hasan today.
But I don't know if that happened. Holy Oh my god, Ludwig did
Oh my god, what?
I was waiting on Ludwig's opinion, so.
I'm trying to find it.
I can't see it.
She's 100% a shot caller. Hey. Probably.
I think he lied about having a shot caller. I think he 100% had
a shot had a shot caller based off what's on my for you page.
I do like I do like how all of this is based on these people
watching I've just noticed this. Everybody gets their news from
Aoc and then Aoc takes people repeating things they saw on his
page as people like independently verifying things he said. And
there's like no checking. It's very funny to me. How this happens.
It's on my for you page. Confirmed on Twitter. Lud- Ludwig has
confirmed what I said on Twitter, so.
That's the same. >> happened with This happened with the
Scar thing. Apparently, the Scar guy was like, "Dan Clancy does
He I I heard he was hanging out with young girls." Then he comes
back and he's like, "Oh, I just heard that from somebody." It's
like, "Yeah, you heard it from somebody who read it on Aoc's
page, dude."
And Aoc just posted as if it's like independent confirmation,
which is very very very funny.
My comments about the CEO Dan Clancy got
saying that I like he was out every
with young girls.
That was
That was based off of a rumor that I've heard from another person,
someone that I trust. But I usually I don't go ahead and say
stuff like this because I feel like it's really easy to dogpile
onto people and cause like random hate trains. I feel bad about
that statement. And like I that's something where it's
Dude, there's no way he goes
Did you hear that? He's like, "Um Listen, I heard that from somebody
I trust." implying it's like true. But normally, I don't say
stuff like that cuz it can cause hate trains like dogpiles on
people. Like, "Okay, why would you go out of your way to say
that it's like true or you think it's true before saying that?
Is that Are you not just saying you're trying to run a a hate
train on Dancing Clancy?" I It's like I
don't want there to be like some weird hate train because of
that. Cuz that's something where like I didn't even personally
see I'm regardless of what I've heard, I There's been a lot of
terrible rumors in the scene that end up
like witch hunting
for the wrong reasons. Do I Now, do I agree with him Oh, hold
on.
Wait, I almost I I'm going to keep watching this at some point.
But I I'm probably going to end the stream soon. Oh, I could
continue some of this stuff with Patreon, too, if I wanted to.
We'll see. Maybe I'm thinking about doing Patreon stream after
this, guys.
Like, did you see the Tectone
Something like that, I think.
The Rich Campbell So, Rich Campbell, you know, had his lawsuit
against him dropped today or recently.
And yeah, Tectone basically just was like sobbing. We watched
his statement what he was saying about Rich. And he just threw
Rich under the bus so badly in 2022.
He was like sobbing about how he was assaulted, how he was raped
when he was a kid, and how it's so [__] up how people
call women liars. I just kept flipping back to this tweet the
whole time. It's so [__] up how people call women
liars about sexual assault and [__] I'm not joking.
He said all this [__]
And how he was so proud of OTK for for asking Rich to step down
within 30 minutes and how like Rich was his best friend and he
couldn't believe this was happening.
He just totally sold Rich down the river. Like he just totally
[__] him
And then he comes out with this statement about Rich today.
Another OnlyFans woman lying about Rich and then just moves on.
As [__] said. ended.
Y'all probably
know what's going on.
Tectone addresses the Rich
>> situation.
The actions of one person affect a lot more than just one person.
There'll be a lot of things coming to an
This 8 minutes
This 8 minutes into my stream yesterday.
8 minutes
that I say
the [__]
the stuff
that we're going to talk about.
Now, I want to talk about what a lot of people here are here
to hear about.
Um in that way, in case that's all they care, you know, they
can go about their
Um let's talk about Rich.
Oh my god.
Uh I want to make one thing perfectly
Here it comes.
Pause my music.
Leave the music. I I played some very inappropriate music during
this earlier,
uh I've seen a lot of people
who like to go online
and say
Tect- Tectone, you're a [__] grown up dude, man.
You're a grown up man.
Uh sorry, chat. That's a very touchy subject for me. Y'all know
why.
A lot of people want to go online
and tell
or men
that their stories
are invalid
they want to come
to the defense
of their content creators.
Wow. Wow.
Is this the same one? Oh, this not the same one. Hold on, particular
sunset. What's What's the tweet you just linked? Have I seen
this one before?
Have we seen this What is this?
Proud to be blocked.
Women who falsely accuse men are scum and should be imprisoned.
So cool. He's so cool.
Oh, hold on.
Where we go?
That does not help anything.
That truly does not help anything.
People should not have to be
of telling their stories online.
Oh, Jesus.
Uh second time in a year I've had to talk about this.
That's really bad.
As a lot of you all know,
have been
affected by
Hold on though. Hold on. My life multiple times.
Just wait. >> I have also
been raped.
And I know the feeling.
I If If somebody can find me
this not censored, I really need it,
Oh, been something. He's been something.
I have also
been raped.
And When was this again? This was 2 years ago
during the Rich stuff. This was his response to the Rich allegations
coming out. Rich getting suspended from OTK or getting asked
to resign from OTK. I know the feeling
when you share your story online
or with your family
and people don't want to believe you.
It takes a lot of bravery to share those
And just because someone waits a little
doesn't mean that it's not true.
It doesn't mean that it is true, but we should not shame anybody
who is sharing their story.
You trust.
We trust.
And then we confirm.
I believe that's how this I believe that's how the saying goes.
In case you guys don't know,
it took me
13 years
to talk about my own.
And so when people want to use that
as an issue, it takes some It takes some time.
It takes some time for people.
So please,
if you see men or women sharing their stories online about your
favorite content creators,
I don't know if he follows this up with kind of selling Rich
down the river as well, but All right, we already watched it
earlier in the stream. It was very embarrassing. It's very sad.
Anyway, I think we're basically done here. Let me see who's online.
Rezi.
Uh maybe she can Rezi raid. Uh Goons also online. I'll I'll shoot
you guys over to Cooner.
Uh Oh, wait. Are we going to do Patreon or something?
Yeah, we can do Patreon. We'll do Patreon supporter stream, guys.
If you guys would hop in the Discord or join the Patreon, um
I think we'll
I'm not totally sure. We might If we do some of this, we might
also watch the Farrah reality TV series, the first
I can find it easily.
>> Wait, you see this You've seen this, right? You've seen
the I saw the tweet. Yeah, I saw the Sherry's tweet.
It's just funny stuff, man. But I think I might want to watch
the rest of the Pisco convo. We'll see.
Sherry's got an idea of what we're going to do, guys. But we'll
uh give us I don't know, 5 10 minutes. We'll do Patreon supporter
stream, supporter or not, if you guys want to join. All right?
So it's discord.gg/jsteelk.
It's
If you sign up for the Patreon, you go through Patreon to integrate
the
the integrate the role into the Discord so you can keep watching,
guys.
All right?
Have a good night, everybody. Uh we're not going to raid out
though. So we'll talk to you all later.
Be back tomorrow.
Bye-bye for now. Yeah.